by the way that guitar sounds really
good that's the that's jimmy page's
guitar that he made can you play almost
every zeppelin riff i mean is that how
you learn how to play guitar that well
is that what you did listen to those
records and then just figure it out yeah
[Music]
lady
[Music]
you know i try to play guitar and i try
to play that riff over and over again
and i always [ __ ] it up
um it's not easy to do that is that how
you teach yourself guitar if i want to
be a great guitar player you listen to
that and just pick it out and figure it
out and do it over and over and over and
over again
yeah well yeah i mean think anything
right ten thousand hours but uh
you know i had a great guitar teacher
who
was so cool because he always was like
hey what do you want to learn you know
what song do you want and i
he would like hey yeah this is a great
song to learn you know to get your chops
better this is a great
zeppelin song and i was 11. you know and
he's like over the hills in far away and
i'm like
oh cool you know and look look that's
[Music]
that's not that easy to do no no and so
like
inadvertently learning that song helped
me get better my dexterity better so
when i was young so like so it's really
cool to learn what you love because if
you learn what you love then you're
going to be good at it because you'll be
doing it all the time but like i
started falling in love with music in
like the late 80s when i was nine years
old so like
appetite for destruction had just come
out and like
all this crazy stuff was happening with
music especially in that vein and so
like i've just learned i was like loved
the hairbands and loved
you know like the crazy amazing guns and
roses is slash a great guitar player
dude you're technically great right is
his stuff hard to play
the way that he would play you can't
just
mimic you sound like a dick if you're
like trying to play his the way he
played because he had so
he has so much feel slash
has so much feel you couldn't play sweet
child the way he plays it
everyone that tries to play sweet
childhood sounds like a dick
yeah but you can't do it unless you do
it like him because there's a whole
like his [ __ ] is there it's like it's
like yeah it's like
you can't do it like he can and if you
because it's a
it's a musically sophisticated part
that's kind of nerdy
but done by slash in a way that gets
laid
you